circulando por las calles y soldados
patrullando colombo es ahora una ciudad
en alerta máxima tras días de violentos
disturbios que han llevado al gobierno
al borde del colapso el ejército fue
desplegado para asegurar el 'toque de
queda' nacional con órdenes de disparar
para evitar más disturbios mientras el
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa intenta
aferrarse al poder
este es un momento en el que los
srilanqueses deben unirse para superar
los retos económicos sociales y
políticos a los que nos enfrentamos
[Música]
pero las llamadas a la calma de
rajapaksa fueron en vano los
manifestantes volvieron a desafiar el
toque de queda el miércoles con una
sentada de protesta frente a la oficina
del presidente
duermevela el gobierno quiere empujar
esta lucha pacífica hacia una lucha
violenta
creemos que solo podemos ganar esta
lucha a través de una lucha no violenta
y pacífica
los manifestantes pacíficos se han
reunido cada noche en colombo durante el
último mes pidiendo la renuncia de la
familia política gobernante
pero las protestas dieron un giro
violento el lunes cuando los partidarios
del ex primer ministro ma jin daraya
pacsa el hermano del presidente en
funciones atacaron a manifestantes
pacíficos como el primer ministro ya
dimitió pero los manifestantes dicen que
no es suficiente decenas de casas de
políticos del partido en el poder han
sido incendiadas los manifestantes
exigen en la dimisión del presidente
rajapaksa culpan al gobierno de la
recesión económica del país que ha
provocado una grave escasez y una
espiral de inflación